Today I'm gonna go over why I absolutely love my chamber stove
while I clean her. Now,
she doesn't need duct tape right here,
but my son loves to open the pantry compartment right here,
so I have tape on there to stop him from opening it.
I had a over spill of chocolate sauce from the top,
so it fell through into the pantry area
where I keep my Dutch oven bread oven,
which if you don't have one of those,
they're really cool. Here is the grill broiler area,
which I get a lot of questions about.
The grill on top, the griddle on top is removable,
and so is the grease catcher on the bottom.
So unless you don't clean,
you don't really have a risk of fire.
This is the bevel that covers up the pilot light.
I did turn the gas off,
so that's the pilot light that lights the flash tubes here
that lights the daisy burners.
So when I turn the gas on,
gas travels through the flash tubes and up into the pilot light
and causes a little mini explosion
that goes through the daisy burner and lights them.
It's pretty cool and I like doing it every time.
It never gets old. Here
you can see some of the chocolate sauce
that spilled down underneath the drip pans.
I had a massive overflow of chocolate sauce
when I walked away from the stove for a second.
So once that happened, I It was time for a deep clean.
She is so beautiful.
And here you can see some more of that chocolate sauce.
It was really bad and burnt,
but all the drip trays and all the pieces come off,
and I put them in soapy water,
and it all came clean pretty easily.
I think my most common question I get is,
what is that stove? It's a Chambers Model C.
It was made here in the USA.
It was a company, a family company that made stoves.
I think their last name was chambers.
From the early 1900s all way up until,
I think the 1970s. They have a 70s model,
which is pretty ugly, but that's when they stopped making them.
This is a Model C. It was made during the 1950s into the early 1960s,
I do believe. This is the pantry area.
It's not an oven,
but it's somewhere where you're supposed to store your dry goods,
which I just keep my bread oven in there.
The other question I get is,
how do you clean the grill area?
Well, all this comes apart.
There's a drip tray that normally goes in here where I keep the, um.
Where I put cooked bacon on.
These are the daisy burners.
They pop in and out. I don't take them out unless I'm cleaning them.
I did paint these, um,
when I put them back, they need to be re enabled,
which is just not something I'm gonna Do right now,
but they are super old. That's why they are like that.
I love the stove,
and I'm never going back to having a regular stove ever again.
This thing is moving with me wherever we go.
That's a bold statement, but I will try to stick to it.
I would literally feel bad if I left her behind.